foreign
hi guys my name is John and I'm with uh
the real rejects ah that feels like a
good place for me
I feel like I'm home I feel like both of
you if you if you want to come on and do
some reaction videos and review some
movies you know you're welcome oh my God
always that's just how I live my life so
why not Perfection well I mean I
appreciate the both of you for uh taking
the time out to talk to me this movie
has been demolishing my heart for the
past week and a half and I hope the both
of you burn in hell for what you did at
Rocket Raccoon
yes Mommy
so sweet of you to say and he didn't see
a match yeah
um
yeah I've been getting so many messages
I'm just like I hate you I was gonna say
dude are people starting to approach you
on the street with like disdain in their
eyes I mean I live in New York City so
yes but uh I think that's just Monday
um I I don't know if people would
recognize me
the thing is I've seen the both of you
before and I had to go oh okay because
yeah you've got all the makeup and and
you're both bald and all that stuff so
yeah but my kids haven't seen it yet and
I'm a little worried about when they do
if I'll have to get an Airbnb for a
little bit before I can book it in
advance Justin in case yeah I love that
you're emotional about it I've been
reading that a lot some people like I've
seen it five times which I was that was
on Saturday I was like how yeah
and well done and thank you for feeling
the feelings I feel your feelings
America world
you heard it here first and and never
before now
um but that's that's a good segue uh
because I feel like you know you both
managed to create memorable characters
out of the types of roles that could
easily fall into that trap of just being
requisite henched types especially when
you're next to such a huge personality
as Chuck as the high evolutionary and
throughout this what I thought was great
is you could feel the wheels turning
under the surface of both vim and Theo
and I got the sense there are probably a
ton of thoughts and feelings that you
can't say out loud in that position but
I got the sense that they were
definitely there so how did you go about
humanizing and inhabiting these two
characters and what notes did you in
particular have in mind for you know how
to play their particular personalities
well for me teal is you know he is a
survivalist
um survival at any cost
um as as what his motivation was and
also his proximity to power you know he
just relishes the fact that he is sort
of like one of the top two people in the
high evolution is life and he will do
whatever to make his master happy
um and that's why he is so evil because
you know he's gonna keep messing with
people because who's gonna mess back
when you got this guy protecting you so
I mean that's what it was for me
um yeah no I mean I think there's some
of that for Vim too and I think the
other thing is that she really has the
hubris to believe that she has a higher
calling right so she's a zealot and uh
believes that and believes herself to
sort of be unemotionally involved and
scientific about it and has that crisis
of realization when you know but that
I'm curious about as a person and as an
actor to to look at that's so human in
our history people who follow the worst
people in the world right over that
Cliff what is that moment when they
realize they're going over the cliff and
would they turn back and do they try to
turn back and what does that look like
you know I mean those are real questions
those are big questions those matter you
know and that's what sci-fi and science
fantasy does so well is asks those huge
questions and has room for them it makes
room for them and that's why I love it
and I love these kinds of stories and so
that was kind of like what I was digging
into too in that moment for her
absolutely it's beautiful and I mean was
that anything I mean how much of that
was your craft to just kind of let left
to play versus what you built with James
and Chuck on on those Dynamics in
particular James and I talked about a
little bit but you know we'd all talk
talked about a little bit about this
being a zealot right and being a
Believer and that high the high
evolutionary High Evo is a Creator and
people who follow the teachings or the
the what the Creator tells them to do no
matter what you know without question
and it's all about your relationship to
your to the Creator right that's kind of
one of the three lines of this movie and
can you change your perception of who
you are and what you were created to do
you know and these people are very much
created to do I mean they have it built
into their skulls yeah so like here's
what to do yeah you're recorder
um so you know there's that but yeah so
some of it was that was talking about it
and and some of it was just like the
nerdy sci-fi nerd in me that was like
I'm allowed right a 62 000 page
dissertation on this and we'll discuss
later
um because that's what I'm all about
and part of being an actor too that's
what I love but yeah and then getting to
work with Chuck and and Nico and like
see how that what that looks like in the
room you know when we actually get it up
on a yeah I think that's that was the
really fun part was sort of
recalibrating your expectation or
perception of the character based on
we're working with your team partners
because I definitely sort of like had my
initial like well this is how I'm
approaching the character but then you
get on set with amazing actors like like
Miriam and Chuck and and James directing
you and you see the performance that
they're giving you and you have no
choice but to sort of narrow that and
give it right back and so it's sort of
just upped everybody's game because
you're working with such incredible
people absolutely and I saw that video
James posted of y'all having like that
dance party on set and whatnot and that
looked super fun for such a grim
circumstance and I I was wondering too
then was there any particular song or or
music type that you used to get into
character to help build kind of the
feeling of the characters well you know
chuck wood chuck had this beautiful
operatic music that he would have in his
scenes in the Laboratories you know and
it's so gorgeous and ominous and really
evocative you know and you couldn't not
I mean the crew like you the DP would be
like you know like you just are so
feeling this when you're in there but
then James would sometimes play the play
how do you play play different songs
maybe played Alice Cooper he would play
different things because he understands
so brilliantly and how music ties
connects you nostalgically to an emotion
the connection to whatever the emotion
in the scene is and that's that's why
the movies work so the music in the
movies work so well yeah and he also
understands
just can I swear am I allowed to swear
it's just so fun
he believes in that fun and I think
that's why people respond to his movies
you know we got the soundtrack for the
movie early on we were given like these
are the songs that are going to be in
the movie you know so you really sort of
like got into the mindset or whatever
that emotion was for the scenes from
when these songs were gonna get plugged
in because James knows how like you said
how important that is for the final
product so it was really helpful to sort
of get that list of songs and be like oh
this is what's going to be playing yeah
yeah it matters to him it matters to him
yeah and that seems like kind of a dream
come true knowing and having that
ability to actually pipe that stuff in
and you know not being worried that
it'll be swapped out for something
completely different later uh yeah it's
like why is Barbie girl playing on this
spot
you know hey I mean Now's the Time if
ever there was a time
ride that wave deals just a Ken
but uh but yeah was there anybody of the
I mean you know you'd spend a lot of
time with chuck on screen but was there
anybody in the main Guardians cast that
you particularly hit it off with or you
know maybe sort of you know you're new
to this found family did anybody kind of
take you under their wing you know what
I'll say is that everyone was welcoming
everyone was kind they've all been doing
this for years okay and then have to you
know they they could have just been like
yeah yeah show up to your job be a
professional which of course they they
were and we were but it wasn't like that
it was like we're all here to play and
that comes from James James immediately
is like I want you here you know you
have a part to play in this thing that I
wrote that we're gonna make together
come on play in the sandbox and you're
like oh well yes you know so it starts
from him and then Chris was just a
delight you know Karen's hilarious first
and foremost you know yeah I have a
little fan crush on you yeah but I think
that was the the really amazing part
about being involved in this production
is that nobody was made to feel like
their job didn't matter it didn't matter
if it was crafty or Chris Pratt's role
everybody was working towards the same
goal making sure this movie gets made
and you know goes right out of the hitch
and that is a labor of love for
everybody not just James
um but yeah we were never made to feel
stupid or dumb for asking questions or
asking for something that we needed more
welcome to open arms and to James
everybody's job was important you were
there to to make this all happen his
level of respect is really important
it's not
a given not a Hollywood set no time
what are you talking about
but I want to say also that Bradley
Cooper who's a freaking Dreamboat genius
we all know we know Brad but he is
you're on record saying this
but uh but Sean Gunn who played rocket
physically when you know then Bradley
puts the voice in somehow brilliantly
later I don't know that I don't
understand his skill but anyway um he's
just too talented it's annoying um but
no but Sean
I mean there were moments that were so
moving do you remember Nico
wow like he when you see his level when
you're working with him and to have
those eyes I mean I I just want to yeah
I want to shout out Sean Gunn too it's
just just an all-around yeah amazing
human but incredible actor incredible
you know that was also really fun to get
to see how that was done you know yeah
we really had to sort of take a moment
at the end of the day to shake out the
evils
break your heart you know really yeah
but it's it's I mean I cried a lot
watching this movie both times yes
this is probably the most I've
consistently cried through a movie since
everything everywhere all at once
probably I was like dehydrated by the
end of it yes yeah it's like I need an
ID
yeah
so that's lovely to know that that that
you know Aura kind of permeated every
step of the process from the production
to just what we get to see as fans and
uh and I'm very curious I I heard you
say in a different interview that you
guys worked out some sort of recorder
Broadway number is there any chance over
the the massive confusion of Zoom to
recreate that a little bit here listen I
it's just it's the pure deep down dork
in me that was like how funny would it
be if these two these two people
they're the perfect two people sort of
like sort of like an 80s sitcom theme
song e Broadway it just seemed like
so that's apparently how I start
um my jobs is I write a ridiculous song
and perform it with my new best friend
from a boss that's what I do yeah they
work do you not do you not do that
listen when when things I'm working on I
try to yeah at least come on first verse
and Chorus at least you know this is
first day this was our first day on set
with this musical thing happened so when
Miriam was like I wrote a musical I was
like you're my best friend yeah and
that's the fact that we were like James
I was doing this thing and he was like
record it
and I was like we're friends we're all
friends yes
okay good good to know good to know you
gotta make sure that winds up on the DVD
extras if I don't know it's on his phone
unless he yeah
well I mean that phone must be in Kevin
feige's Vault somewhere
yeah I don't know I'll do anything
anything for a laugh apparently I mean
in an environment like this that is that
is a good thing I would say
um and then I guess you know one thing I
I I'm required by law as a nerd to ask
is you know with James now heading up
the DC Universe and everybody says
you're like we love working with James
you know like I'm sure it would be
lovely to join with him but is there any
character over there if you were given
just carte blanche to play anyone you
know would you want to jump into that
side of things or are you ready to get
back massive
sounds like you're saying I look like
Wonder Woman that's what I heard you say
that's basically what I think
I
think we should play the Wonder Twins
Wonder Twins yeah
I'm totally your slip bucket of water
that will yes not at all twins Jesus
Christ
why start this hashtag right now
um
for Wonder Twins I literally get so
frustrated because I would be like why
are they do
full In This Moment
your powers
why is there an eagle and what is that
monkey doing Jesus yeah just join up The
Peacemaker season two uh intro you can
do all the dance moves there yeah I do
love that dance I think
you know you love James Gunn that's when
you're like when you've learned the day
yeah exactly well when you when you see
the dance you're like anyone else Gotta
Dance to their opening no no you don't
[Laughter]
wow
well guys I I'm being given the the
vehement wrap up sign but it has been
such a joy and a pleasure talking to the
both of you thank you just for being so
open and jovial and for making my day as
a fan and just you know as a as a you
know theater kid and all the other stuff
you know it's been a real Joy so I
appreciate it you're welcome and thank
you yeah thank you appreciate it and
you're welcome on the channel anytime
you heard it here
oh
again I heard him say I look like Wonder
Woman is that not what he said I heard
it I heard it
[Music]